Marion Cotillard longtime love glue Liam  kinase speaks out on the Brad Pitt  affair rumors the 43 year old French  actor took to Instagram on Friday to  defend his relationship and his ladylove  posting this pic along with a lengthy  caption that reads in part I don't  usually make it a habit to comment on  rumors made about us  the haters who feel braver behind a  keyboard drive me to speak of the pride  love and respect and admiration I have  for Marion staying as strong and  intelligent in the face of all these  stupid and unfounded accusations  this comes after rumors of an on-set  affair between Brad and Marion swirled  following the news that Angelina Jolie  split from Pitt after two years of  marriage the pair star in the upcoming  World War Two drama allied and Coty are  shut down the rumours herself in a  lengthy Instagram caption she even  revealed she's pregnant with her and  kanae's second child